what are some of the things that you
learned from Tim Cook Tim and I met at
the gym Equinox in Palo Alto at five
every single morning there was like
eight people that would show up at that
same time every day someone came up to
me and was like do you know who that is
I said no I said that's Tim Cook the CEO
of Apple and I was like damn I didn't
know that I've been talking to this guy
for six months I was probably sounding
like an idiot so I cold emailed him
within five minutes he replied we ended
up having breakfast and basically it led
to what you know what has now been 10
plus a year like wonderful relationship
mentorship went to the Berkshire
Hathaway annual meeting with him one
year got to meet Warren Buffett really
yeah I mean it was like incredible